[Music]
on this monday night a painful
anniversary
marking one year since the revelation of
hundreds of suspected unmarked graves
near bc residential school we honor the
children who suffered the lives gone
unfulfilled the day's significance to
survivors and the hope future
generations can heal
thousands of ontarians powerless the
tough task ahead for hydro crews and how
long it will take to fix
the first russian soldiers sentenced for
war crimes in ukraine as another major
company drops out of russia forever
and moving the needle vaccine absolutely
outweighs the risk
inching closer to inoculating kids under
five against covid
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us it
was one year ago today the to come loops
to schweitman first nation in bc
confirmed 215 unmarked presumed graves
at the site of a former residential
school
from sunrise to sunset today members of
the community and those visiting from
across the province and the country are
honoring the children who never returned
home
anita garcia is at the ceremonies in
kamloops today and joins us now
well colleen you can hear the drumming
behind me there have been public
speeches song and dance since nine
o'clock this morning here at the pow wow
arbor the same grounds that this
community came to grieve in a year ago
and the same venue that cook p or chief
roseanne kasmir hoped to welcome pope
francis to during his visit to canada
for reconciliation this summer she
expressed her disappointment here today
that the pontiff summer schedule does
not include a stop here in what's known
as round zero of canada's reckoning
around residential schools but she said
as hundreds of survivors and community
members politicians of all levels of
government and canada's governor general
gather here it is certainly a reminder
that there is much more work to do and
it won't take away from the significance
and meaning of this event
[Music]
the sounds of the songs institutions
like the former kamloops indian
residential school tried to eradicate
are being heard more loudly a year after
the announcement that changed the
country's understanding of its own
history say community members here
this
has been a very dark chapter in our
history and we need to rebuild our
relationships
at every single level
it shouldn't have taken that long
but finally
people know
and knowing
has transformed this community
after a year spent grieving and
processing hundreds gathering at the
sacred pow-wow arbor to honor the
children whose lives were taken after
being forced into the kamloops indian
residential school
because i knew how to read they had me
you know reading the bible to the
everybody in in the church
and i was probably maybe about
nine three generations of colleen jacobs
family were sent here she says the
relentless assimilation demanded by the
institution tore her family apart my
brother and i were separated i also
remember
always having to line up
and maybe that's why i don't like
lineups for her this day is about
healing and having hope for younger
generations it is a
new time
and i think it's time for us to start
building up our young people but they
also need to know the truth what they
went through trickled down to me
for 19 year old shelby sims the impact
is through indigenous child welfare what
many call the modern day residential
school system i just want to be with my
culture i want to connect with my people
she suffers from fetal alcohol syndrome
like her mother who was deemed unfit to
care for her so sims was raised by her
grandparents from birth and says because
of their own traumas they denied her
access to her indigenous heritage
i cannot sing i cannot drum i cannot
dance but i will stand and i will be
there and i'll be present for them
an example of how impacts of the
systemic erasure of indigenous culture
continues today during an event meant to
foster hope for a better future
now cook p roseanne kasmir said pope
francis not responding to her invitation
to come here was like deja vu from when
prime minister justin trudeau did the
same on the country's first national day
for truth and reconciliation but
survivors tell us trudeau who is in fact
here today will be expected to do more
than just make an appearance but to also
show how his government which will be
remembered in history as the one in
power during this historic moment plans
to commit to making reconciliation a
reality colleen
mithu gotcha in kamloops bbc thank you
thank you
and a reminder there is support
available for survivors of residential
schools and their families the number is
toll-free 24 hours a day it is
1-800-721-0066
at least 10 people are dead after a
storm tore through southern ontario and
eastern quebec saturday leaving behind a
path of destruction
hundreds of thousands of people are
still without power including in
uxbridge ontario where this drone
footage was taken the cleanup is
underway as people begin to survey the
extent of the damage which includes
downed trees branches poles and power
lines impacting massive areas of the
electrical grid mike delay looks at how
long it might be before people get their
electricity back
the steeple at the san eugen parish has
stood as something of a beacon for the
small town of sarsfield just east of
ottawa since 1895. for all the storms
and winters it's seen it was saturday's
winds that toppled it over there is no
band-aid fixed to the storm damage with
four transmission lines down and over
800 hydro poles snapped in two parts of
southern ottawa are still without power
the nearest fast food restaurants that
were open were flooded with people
looking for a hot meal
and it didn't take long for the gas
pumps to run dry i wasn't expecting it
to be as strong couldn't keep ahead of
the storm nobody expected the storm to
move as quickly as it did surprising
even veteran weather chaser mark
robinson when i got caught in it it was
it hit so fast that all i had time went
to do was get out one camera
we now know it was a directio a rare
weather phenomenon that involves a long
line of storms with near tornado-like
winds only without rotation ontario
hasn't seen one since the 1990s now that
the storm has passed we can track its
path through power outages from southern
ontario all the way through ottawa
the scope of the damage is near
unimaginable for hydro crews to tackle
premier doug ford toured the community
of uxbridge which might not get power
fully restored for a week this is a
one once in a lifetime storm like this
that came through
ontario the northern tornado project
from western university is still
analyzing the damage but it has yet to
confirm any official twisters touched
down
whatever their conclusions what matters
most to residents is untangling the mess
the storm created my lawyers here
helping me
my nephew came from halifax to help me
considering the damage they may have to
stay a while mike durlay global news
toronto
it's less a problem here in canada but
south of the border american families
are in crisis as the u.s struggles with
a serious shortage of infant food the
situation now so dire the u.s military
has begun airlifting supplies of baby
formula from europe and as jackson
proskow reports dozens of babies have
been hospitalized as parents struggled
to find them proper nutrition
relief landed in indianapolis as the
first plane load of precious cargo
arrived from europe hypoallergenic baby
formula delivered by the u.s military
i'm told that this shipment provides
enough formula
to take care of nine thousand babies and
eighteen thousand toddlers
uh for a week this remarkable airlift
will bring 1.5 million bottles of
specialized formula to hospitals and
doctors offices across the u.s at a time
when supplies are perilously low
it's situation critical for parents like
megan and steven gendig their
two-month-old daughter has a dairy
allergy it's a terrifying feeling to
know that you don't know where the next
meal is
the crisis began after a voluntary
recall and plant closure by one of the
largest formula manufacturers
in the u.s an estimated 41 percent of
shelves are now empty parents can spend
hours searching online or driving long
distances to find food so it's been
pretty difficult for us to
navigate now that we're literally on our
last can in the last week the shortage
has started to spill across the border
with some canadian stores seeing signs
of panic buying by worried parents
but it's the u.s situation that's
increasingly dire dozens of infants have
been hospitalized for malnutrition
parents like candace hendricks have to
rely on samples from their pediatrician
for three-month-old cason my worst fear
is that when i call to schedule a pickup
for samples that they will say
sorry
that they don't have any more
relief may not come until the end of
summer while the factory at the center
of the shortage plans to restart
production formula stocks will take
months to stabilize
leaving parents on the hunt for this
critical supply
jackson prosco global news washington
the first russian soldiers sentenced for
war crimes in ukraine coming up with a
punishment for the 21 year old tank
commander plus the u.s president's
startling remarks about taiwan and
china's response
u.s president joe biden made a startling
vow during a visit to japan this week
despite his country's long-standing
ambiguity over taiwan he warned his
military would intervene should china
ever try to invade it
they're already flirting with danger
right now by flying so close and all the
maneuvers are undertaken but the idea
that
that it can be taken by force
just taken by force is just not it's
just not appropriate to dislocate the
entire region
biden also drew links to russia's
invasion of ukraine in his comments
though white house officials say his
words don't reflect a policy shift
regarding the island nation china has
long regarded taiwan as a breakaway
province and has increased military
presence near it in recent years in
response beijing's foreign ministry
warned it will take firm action to
safeguard its sovereignty and security
interests
tomorrow will be exactly three months
since russia's large-scale invasion of
ukraine the slow and bloody battles for
land continue across ukraine's east and
president vladimir zelinski says his
forces may be losing between 50 to 100
troops a day addressing the world
economic forum zelensky appealed for
increased and coordinated sanctions
against russia to stem the flow of funds
to the country as redmond shannon
reports it also comes on the day a
russian soldier was handed a life
sentence for war crimes
a ukrainian judge sentences vadim
shishmarin to life in prison the russian
tank commander had admitted to shooting
a civilian riding a bicycle but claimed
he was acting on orders his lawyer says
he will appeal this was the first of
many alleged war crime cases being
pursued by ukraine it's now likely
russia will also try many of the
ukrainian soldiers it has captured too
the specter of war crimes is at the
heart of ukraine's diplomatic drive in
davos at the annual world economic forum
emotional speeches from ukrainian medics
and mayors aimed at the heartstrings of
those who hold the world's purse strings
this wall is really a turning point of
history
and it will reshape our political and
our economic landscape in the coming
years your courageous leadership
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
told attendees the death toll from an
airstrike near kiev last week now totals
87 and that dozens of ukrainians are
dying every day in the donbass zielinski
asked for yet more coordinated sanctions
and for all businesses to shun russian
money every day getting up thinking what
are we doing for the world with respect
to that unity
that was the message that really hit
home to me reminders at davos that while
the global economic impact of this war
has hit fuel it is also critically
affected food before ukraine i was
already out there with a clarion call
that we've got a world food crisis and
we're facing the worst humanitarian
crisis since world war ii so now because
of this crisis we're taking food from
the hungry to give to the starving it's
absolutely a crisis mode the un's world
food program says opening ukraine's
ports to export its grain must be a
priority to prevent a world food crisis
from spinning out of control redmond
shannon global news london
after 15 years in russia starbucks is
joining companies like mcdonald's and
exxon mobil and leaving the country
completely in a memo sent to employees
starbucks says it will close its 130
locations but will continue to pay its
russian employees for six months to help
them with the transition to new jobs for
months consumers and investors have
pressured western companies like
starbucks to cut ties with russia
starbucks suspended all business in
russia at the beginning of march
crowds gathered in kiev today for the
launch of a new postage stamp featuring
destroyed russian warship moskva
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
signed some of the stamps and opened the
sale alongside the head of the country's
postal service more than a month after
the first successful launch with stamp
featuring the same design this new stamp
is dedicated to the actual sinking of
the ship after the first stamp became a
popular souvenir the ukrainian postal
service hopes to repeat its success with
an even larger run this time
a dose of optimism still ahead the new
data on the covet vaccine for kids under
five
you're watching global national
[Music]
families with young children are closer
to a long-awaited vaccine against cobit
19. kids between the ages of six months
and five years are the only age group in
canada currently without access to
vaccines but that could change shortly
based on promising test results by
pfizer ross lord reports
for the most part the very young have
been spared the devastating effects of
covert 19 but there are tragic
exceptions and in the united states
covet is blamed for hundreds of deaths
of children under the age of five an age
category that's not currently eligible
for vaccines that's likely to change
very soon based on clinical trials by
the pharmaceutical giant pfizer which
included three doses administered to
almost 1700 recipients over several
months
in a statement pfizer says our
formulation for the youngest children
which we carefully selected to be one
tenth of the dose strength for adults
was well tolerated and produced a strong
immune response
pfizer and his partner bioentec planned
to take their findings to u.s regulators
this week claiming the new vaccine is 80
percent effective the risks are minute
the benefits might be small given the
fact that the pandemic is waning to some
extent and the and the threat posted
children is somewhat small compared to
adults
but the comparing the two vaccine
absolutely outweighs the risk
epidemiologist ray watt deonandum
believes the vaccine will also remove
the fear factor for parents of very
young children
parents
like him for my kid for example is going
to day care in september i'm pretty
confident now that he'll have
some strong immunity when he goes to
daycare in the fall that's that's
exciting if approved by government
regulators the vaccine will fill a big
gap out of 85 million doses administered
in canada vaccination coverage is
highest in adults aged 60 and older at
almost 94 percent fully vaccinated
canadians between 12 and 60 are also
well protected in the mid to high 80s
there's a big drop to 42 percent for
younger children the under five category
is virtually empty with no approved
vaccine more than two years after the
pandemic started
regulatory approval could come within
days adding to pfizer's nearly
billion u.s dollars in covet vaccine
sales and adding another layer of safety
as the pandemic drags on
ross lord global news
the world health organization says it
expects to find more monkey pox cases as
it expands surveillance in countries
where the disease isn't typically found
but experts stress the cases identified
so far have not been severe
and the thing i just want to say here is
that this is a containable situation
particularly in the countries like where
we are seeing these outbreaks that are
happening across europe
in
north america as well
there are now more than 100 suspected
and confirmed cases in more than a dozen
countries including canada it's believed
the unprecedented spread may have begun
at two raves in spain and belgium
celebrating a man who was so much more
than a tap dance legend next
honey the 1969 fender mustang electric
guitar nirvana frontman kirk cobain
played in this 1991 music video has just
been auctioned off billionaire jim irsay
who owns the indianapolis colts bought
the guitar for a staggering four and a
half million dollars it was expected to
fetch only six hundred thousand cobain's
family is donating part of the proceeds
to mental health initiatives
ahead of national tap dance day on
wednesday some talented young dancers in
calgary are stepping up to salute a
legend on may 25th
tap dance great bilbo jangles robinson
was born as gil tucker shows us the
students are celebrating robinson's
legacy of promoting civil rights and the
dance style they love
tapping into something they can't get
enough of it's like a musical instrument
but like with your feet
so it's like a whole different like way
of making sound and making rhythms which
that's why i really like it excited
while getting ready for a big show this
weekend it's been a while since the last
one it was february 2020. it was an
amazing show but then kovid
made us stop
polishing up their versions of a couple
of classics the shim sham shimmy so
that's the national anthem of tact and
people all over the world know it
part of a group of 80 performers hitting
a calgary stage to mark international
tap dance day
honoring the birthday of a legend bilbo
jingles
he was not only like an amazing tap
dance artist but he was also a civil
rights activist and broke a lot of
racial and social barriers
he's definitely a huge inspiration i
think to every top dancer
it's very important for us to remember
him and acknowledge his work and fight
for everyone to have equal rights one
two one two three four
stepping up to work on that and to
celebrate the joy that tap dance brings
to people's lives
people can come to the national music
center where we are doing pop-up
performances and all of a sudden
there'll be a tap dance piece a body
percussion piece a movement piece live
musicians playing improvisation tap
battles going on
but overall it's just a gathering to
celebrate this art form and this legacy
bill tucker global news
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm colleen christie
we leave you tonight with more of
today's ceremonies in kamloops bc where
members of the tecumless deschwetmick
and other first nations gathered to
honor the children lost to the kamloops
residential school on this the first
anniversary hundreds of suspected graves
were revealed there thanks for watching
and good night
[Applause]